a saturday right because i
i want to have an extravaganza for my
wedding
that sounds okay like a nightmare yeah
yeah i mean i'm going to have
so many people there i'm going to have
iraq people
i'm going to have old friends from high
school i'm gonna have um comedians
actors all kinds of people
right and i would love to invite anthony
right because he's never been invited to
a wedding i
i right before the pandemic i actually
did go megan gailey one of my uh one of
my
openers uh got married to uh her husband
cj
and i i went to that i went out to palm
springs and was there
no went solo who's making it the girl
who hates you oh that's right because
you told her to know you opened for her
in san antonio no she opened for me yeah
yes yeah in chicago in chicago
yeah and you gave her a hard time about
oh that's who megan gailey i wish i
hadn't brought up her name
[Music]
and you're in the wrong for that all
right fine but let me defend myself
okay all right
i'm sure she's a nice woman and you're
friends with her
lover to death like it's like a sister
and i've heard the story
what's the story what's the story i what
it sounds to me and i'll be as played as
i can be
you were having a tough time that
weekend just being on the road i don't
know if you were lonely or like what
weren't enjoying the shows
and kind of took it out on the green
room no part of it no that's not what it
was
this is a very vague i don't know the
details she told me the story and it's
not like something she
she uh talks about a lot it was just i
think we were in the same
old place and she she brought it up but
you gave her a hard time
okay all i did all right sorry i can't
defend you with this
i'm no i'm not defending myself i i want
to apologize to megan galey
yeah can i do that all right i'm just
going to tell you my point of view
though real quick
okay we already we already talked about
that too and your point of view really
is not a good one either
but go ahead we can try we can try remix
it okay we'll remix
so just just just to throw it out there
before you even start
megan gailey consummate professional i
cannot imagine a world in which she was
in the wrong here but go ahead
that's a tough one man you gotta get out
of there yeah all right so
number one i was having a great time
i was having a great time um great
numbers at the club it's a huge club
right and also i wasn't lonely because
jade cataprida
was my feature all right so she's a
friend of mine
so um one night megan gailey um
dressed in a ballroom gown
as an emcee and i just
look at this look i'm waiting i'm
waiting for the part that that you think
she's at fault for
exactly right right you didn't like the
way she was dressed
you're empty yeah you know what let's
back up for a second
i'm in the wrong we've already told you
i'm in the wrong i'm in the wrong i'm in
the wrong and what i shouldn't have done
is what i did
and i feel bad about it and um
i just found it was a weird energy her
going up with a ballroom gown yeah but
bobby no one makes a fuss out of what
you wear and sometimes you wear
construction gear too
i'm the headliner i think the big
it's my show you might be having a bad
time you've been on the road a long time
you just start to get you like the
gravity becomes heavier and you're just
not yourself
you know it's like you you're starting
to be a jerk and you're like why am i
being a jerk right now you're like oh i
haven't eaten all day
you know it's like one of those degrees
i've been traveling too
what it is i'm in a bad mood now
probably didn't have sugar-free red bull
yeah something all right here's what i
hear i'm taking on people around here's
what i want
and see if you can pull this off george
okay
and i am going to um can you invite her
to do
our podcast okay good
[ __ ] luck i don't think i can
i think you can invite her okay i want
to apologize to her
right i'm gonna buy her gifts here this
is why it's already not gonna work why
why don't without it you turning it into
a show
apologize to someone genuinely and in
private
that's the thing with comics now is
they're like let's talk it out on the
air and it's like
no you wanna if you gotta if we've got a
problem we can talk it out as people
okay can you find me her email well you
can just find her on instagram that's an
easy one dm are saying look i'll direct
message her
on instagram all right because i'm not
we're not following each other so it's
going to go to her other group of
groupings and she's not going to read it
because i did that with uh
a bunch of guys right they don't read it
uh-huh that's correct right so it's like
should i just give it a go on
instagram just give it a go also you
have friends that know her santino knows
her they're friends
anthony knows her yeah i think she had a
negative experience with you and it was
a small one
but so it's not like the end of the
world like there have been people that
i'm like that guy's a [ __ ] dick he's
like no he's normally cool and then you
get to know them you're like
oh i just had i i met them on a bad day
that i don't know what was going on in
their life maybe i was in a bad mood
yeah
so it's like you can give people second
chances you hear a reputation you meet
them you're like oh you're different
than that
you know that's my that's my you know
what that's my lifelong goal and i'm not
gonna do it on air
right this i'm not gonna do it on air
and
and i am in the wrong i just really feel
that
and i feel bad about it and i um
you know here's another thing is i have
little fires everywhere
uh-huh me too i have little fires
everywhere and i think that i think this
next year
i'm going to put those fires out but
they're like i've gotten fights with mcs
before
you know i'm in a club but the mc does
something that i don't like i had an
emcee once
megan was my feature and the mc tweeted
like
ever been in a green room and had no one
talk to you not fun
and like i found out after the weekend
that i was like i would have fired her
that second
and i'll never see this girl again so
who gives a [ __ ] yeah but sometimes you
like
i'll never see them again who cares we
had a bad interaction but then they keep
going and you're like
okay now we're in the same we're in the
same universe and
i should fix this you know i've thought
about it differently yeah i've seen you
as a different person
yeah but i'm i'm totally all for having
a bad experience and writing someone off
forever i will cut the cord yeah yeah i
think in megan galey's case
um that i i was in the wrong
and i know it i was in a mood i'll tell
you what was going on in my life
all right you weren't doing well i
wasn't doing well in my career
um i was desperate all i had was the
road
and that was the only thing that was
making me money i didn't have any real
podcasts no podcasts at the time i had
nothing going on
you know and now i was living in the
apartment too right
yeah yeah and and this was before i met
you
oh it's before i met her even so i was
in a re then that was in a real bad
state
desperate you know and i um
since i met you my life has completely
changed 180 and you know things are
great
are you talking to me or her just in
general okay
megan or anthony oh so yeah i'm talking
to megan right now
right and so um i'm just talking to
myself i'm just i'm thinking out loud
right now what we've been doing talking
about megan gailey is more than megan
gailey has thought about this in her
entire life
that's true like she does not think
about this like she would be i'm sure
she would accept your apology and be
like okay
if you want to talk but like she this is
not something that she like falls asleep
thinking about
she ran into an [ __ ] you ever heard
that hear that phrase if you
if you wake up one day you run into an
[ __ ] in the morning it hurts you ran
into an [ __ ]
yeah you run into [ __ ] all day
you're the [ __ ]
right guess which one he's the [ __ ]
i'm the [ __ ]
but um you're right
i was an [ __ ] uh-huh all right but
it's okay to be not you could you're
allowed to slip up
and be an [ __ ] like i've just been
under a lot of pressure on the road and
like
when i snap at somebody backstage i'm
like that's not normally not what i'm
like and if i can apologize sure
if i never see them again that's okay
too give
give yourself permission to slip up
every now and again but yeah you can
make it right make it right
no but if but but to be honest with you
if i was in the wrong
i have to make amends because you know
i'll be honest
another honest thing is that i've only
heard
great things about her on stage and
office day that she's a sweet girl she's
friends
with so many people that i know and um
i've been trying for years to get people
off my side
yeah this is the last stop and i just
realized that um i'm
100 in the wrong you know what i mean
and my ego got in the way and i was an
[ __ ] and i was in a bad place in my
career
and i was acting out and i was treating
people like [ __ ] because i was like
feeling [ __ ] about myself
and i would never do that today ever
right i'm just so
different you really got it together now
i feel it thank you and um
you know honestly i feel like i feel now
like i did when i started like in the
beginning of when i
in 2000 when i was getting [ __ ] and i
was
you know getting the tonight show all
these things and then i spent 15 years
with nothing and then i feel now
reinvented again and i think that
that's what's great about stand-up is
that we can
there's always a shot of staying
in it you can focus on stand-ups like
these other these tv things they'll come
they'll go whatever but you can you you
have to stand up you can control
you're you're the master of your own
destiny i believe is the phrase